Dr. Scholl's.
Born to Move.
>> Laura: TEAM FOR THE SEEN AN
UNSEEN SEGMENT WHERE WE EXPOSE
WHAT IS GOING ON BEHIND THE
CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY.
HERE NOW TO FILL US IN, RAYMOND
AROYO.
RAYMOND, LET'S START WITH THIS
COLUMNIST WITH "THE WASHINGTON
POST."
RUTH MARCUS WHO USED TO FOCUS ON
POLITICS AND NOW SHE WROTE A
COLUMN IF SHE HAD A DOWNS
SYNDROME CHILD, SHE WOULD HAVE
ABORTED THE CHILD.
>> THE TITLE WAS "I WOULD HAVE
ABORTED A FETUS WITH DOWNS
SYNDROME, WOMEN NEED THE RIGHT."
IT'S TERRIFYING.
SHE TALKED ABOUT WHEN SHE HAD
TWO PREGNANCIES AND SHE TOOK THE
DOWNS SYNDROME TEST.
SHE WRITES, I'M GOING TO BE
BLUNT HERE.
THAT WAS NOT THE CHILD I WANTED
IF IT WAS POSITIVE.
THAT WAS NOT THE CHILD OR THE
CHOICE I WOULD HAVE MADE.
YOU CAN CALL ME SELFISH OR
WORSE, BUT I'M IN GOOD COMPANY.
THAT EVIDENCE IS CLEAR THAT MOST
WOMEN CONFRONTED WITH THE SAME
UNHAPPY ALTERNATIVE WOULD MAKE
THE SAME DECISION.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, PEOPLE ARE
TERRIFIED AND HORRIFIED WHEN
THEY READ THAT.
>> Laura: SO ALL THE KIDS THAT
ARE AMAZING ANGELS WHO ARE KIDS
WITH DOWNS SYNDROME AND WHOSE
CHANGED FAMILIES AND -- YEAH, IT
CAN BE -- IT IS CHALLENGING.
HOW DO YOU THAT FEEL AFTER
READING THAT?
>> THAT WAS NOT THE CHILD I
WANTED.
WHAT OTHER CHILDREN DON'T YOU
LIKE, RUTH?
WHAT OTHER QUALITIES OR
GENETIC --
>> Laura: THAT'S COMING.
WHAT IF YOU SCREEN FOR CANCER?
I HAD BREAST CANCER.
NO, WE DON'T WANT THAT ONE.
>> YOU CAN SCREEN FOR EYE COLOR,
SCREEN FOR SEX.
HAIR COLOR.
WHAT IF YOU DON'T LIKE THOUGH
ATTRIBUTES?
>> Laura: AND FUTURE POLITICAL
DESIGNATION?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THEY CAN TEST
FOR THAT YET.
>> Laura: THAT IS COMING.
KEEP HER OUT.
>> ANY ONE THAT SPENDS TIME WITH
CHILDREN WITH DOWNS, THEY HAVE A
CAPACITY FOR LOVE AND EMPATHY.
RUTH MARCUS NEEDS TO SPEND MORE
TIME WITH THEM.
SHE MIGHT LEARN SOMETHING.
>> Laura: WHAT IS GOING ON,
FIVE-YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF POPE
FRANCIS
FRANCI
FRANCIS.
>> ON A COMPETING NECESSARY
WORK.
>> Laura: I REMEMBER YOUR FACE.
>> I WAS.
>> Laura: WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
THIS P.R. CAMPAIGN THAT SEEMS TO
BE LAUNCHED BY THE VATICAN FIVE
YEARS LATER?
>> AS YOU'RE SEEING THIS IS
FOOTAGE FROM A NEW DOCUMENTARY,
CALLED "POPE FRANCIS, A MAN OF
HIS WORD".
>> Laura: DO YOU HAVE TO SAY
THAT?
YOU'RE THE POPE.
>> THE DOCUMENTARIAN WAS
RECRUITED TO DO THIS BY THE
VATICAN.
WHY IS THE VATICAN FUNDING A
FILM ABOUT THEIR BOSS?
THEY ARE.